And behold,
the word of the Lord came unto him
saying,
this shall not be there in heir,
but he that shall come forth out of the
bottle,
should be nine here.
So he gets promised the impossible once
again,
and he brought him forth abroad and
said,
now look towards the heaven and tell the
stars if that will be able to number
them.
And he said unto him,
so shall thy seed be,
and he believed in the Lord and he
counted to him for righteousness.
Seeing that this,
this,
this is the covenant idea,
this belief,
because here's the belief.
It's the willingness to act as if the
world is constructed so that if you do
the right thing,
the best possible outcome will occur.
It's a decision.
That's the covenant,
right?
So decision about how to live in the
world because the evidence can't be
there before you make the decision,
right?
And so you might hedge your bets.
You know when,
when Christ comes back in the book of
revelation to judge people because he
comes back as a judge and virtually
everyone gets cast out with the chaff
and not saved with the wheat,
and he says something very interesting.
He appears in division with a sword
coming out of his mouth.
It's a horrifying vision and he divides
the,
the he divides humanity into the damned
and the save or the day.
Yes,
the damned and the saved.
He says something very interesting.
He says
to those who were neither hot nor cold,
I will spew you out of my mouth.
And,
and it's,
it's a,
it's a disgust metaphor.
Right?
And what it says is that the worst
punishment isn't waiting for those who
committed to something and did wrong.
The worst punishment is reserved for
those who committed to nothing and
stayed on the fence.
And that's really something to.
That's really something to think about.
And it's also something that I believe
to be true because I see that stacy,
this is utterly destructive because
there's no progress.
All the resist movement backwards.
There's aging and suffering and no
progress.
And so to not commit to anything is the
worst of all.
Transgressions.
To commit means to put your body and
soul into something.
To offer your life as a sacrifice means
that you're willing to make a bargain
with fate and the bargain is I'm going
to act as if if I give it my all,
then the best possible thing will happen
because of that and to not see the
analogy between that and the the active
faith in God is to misunderstand the
story completely and it has to be an
active faith because how are you going
to know?
You can look at other people,
but that isn't going to do it.
It's at Kierkegaard was very clear about
this sort of thing.
There's certain sorts of truth that you
can only learn for yourself through
experience.
And that's of course why Abraham also
has to go out alone,
right?
He has to leave this candidates.
It's an individual.
It's the individuation process like
dying.
It's something that you do alone.
There's no way you can tell what is
within your grasp,
let's say,
unless you make the ultimate sacrifice
and there's no way of finding out
without actually making it,
and so that's the sacrificial act,
right?
That's,
that's really emphasized in the act of
Abraham being called upon to sacrifice.
Isaac,
you think about that is Abraham,
he's been doing.
He's been like breaking himself into
pieces,
trying to progress forward through
starvation and tyranny and war and
deceit and the potential loss of his
wife and childlessness and like
everything that can really be fall you
in some sense.
And finally God grants him Isaac when
he's old,
it's impossibly gets Isaac,
his son,
and then what does God do next is say,
well,
you know,
that son that you've been waiting for.
So for so long it's like,
I'd like to see just exactly what you're
made of.
So I think you should offer him up as a
sacrifice.
And I mean it's a very barbaric story in
a sense,
and maybe in more than just the sense,
but Abraham does maintain his covenant.
He's willing to make the sacrifice he's
made,
willing to make.
This is the thing,
he's willing to make whatever sacrifices
necessary to keep his covenant with God
in Tack,
and that's that.